At least some of the stuff that I'm thinking of right now, you know, you can see me, Joel.
Justin's holding himself back.
He's like, his blood pressure is 180 over 30.
You know, like, yeah.
And so, man, my heart's going to explode, Joel.
Man.
All right, we're rolling.
Man, I just feel like somebody stabbed me in the heart with a knife, man.
Oh, yeah?
Did you just get doomed or something?
What happened?
I just got a message on one of my reports for the live hacking event that's like, hey, there's, like, this mitigating factor to your most impactful report.
And it just, like, and it just hit right before the pod, too.
So I'm like, oh, so now I'm just, I can't stop thinking about, like, how am I going to bypass that?
How am I going to bypass that?
But, you know, it happens.
It's the life of a bug bounty hunter.
Yeah, yeah, man.
That's rough.
That sucks.
I hate it when that happens.
We should maybe have a new policy that you shouldn't check your email right before the pod.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Yeah, I got to, I don't know, man.
I got to, I get the push notifications on my phone, obviously, for my email.
And then as soon as I see it's, like, from HackerOne related stuff, it's, like, crack.
Like, I got to open that shit right away, you know?
And, but sometimes it comes across pretty hard.
And, man, my fickle heart.
Yeah, I had one of those yesterday morning, too.
I was, like, just waking up.
I was going through my inbox.
And I was, like, oh, hey, they finally updated their report that I reported before the weekend.
I go and I check.
And they're, like, oh, actually, this is informative.
I was, like, oh, no.
I hate it.
Still happens.
Still happens, man.
Actually, you know, I don't know what's up with this event.
And I'm glad my sort of QA process caught it.
But I've actually had two or three false positives this event that I was getting ready to submit.
And I was, like, wait, maybe I should just run through this again.
And then I run through it again.
And it's, you know, I got something messed up.
And it's, like, ah, it just takes the wind out of you so bad.
I hate that.
Yeah, we had that happen a couple times as well, where it's, like, things were behaving, like, super weird.
And we're, like, hmm, maybe this is, like, a bug.
We should probably report it.
Let's just double check it and, like, run it through.
It just doesn't work again.
Yeah.
Are you working with someone for this event?
I'm working with a bunch of different people on just, like, little different things.
Just collabing around?
Yeah, it's just, like, little bugs.
Like, if they have, like, one thing that they want to, like, work on, we'll, like, go.
We'll jam on that.
And then, like, I'll go and I'll mess with something by myself.
And then I'll hop over to somebody else.
And, yeah.
Nice.
I think we're, like, five or six days into the event now.
And I've got, like, four or five bugs.
And I hope this impactful one that I kind of, you know, rabbit holed on, I hope I can figure it out.
Because if I can't, that's going to be painful for sure.
But it's a little bit slower than usual.
But the scope for this event is a little bit tricky.
So I'm happy with it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's really interesting.
I was just commenting to somebody else that, like, these big events are fun.
But also, like, not as fun, I think.
Just because, for one, like, there's so much scope that it's almost hard to, like, figure out what you should be looking at and trying to optimize.
And then usually the larger events have more hackers, which is more intimidating.
There's more reports.
It's, like, right now, I won't say who, but, like, one of the targets, there's two targets.
One of the targets has, like, 150 reports or something already.
The other one has, like, 80.
And, like, one person alone has, like, 70 reports on one of the targets.
So it's, like...
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy.
There's, like, a lot, a lot.
So for me, like, the imposter syndrome and the, like, oh, man, I'm just going to deep on everything.
That's, like, huge right now.
But you've got to, like, figure out ways to navigate through that.
Yeah.
It's events like these where you've got to really stick to the tips that you preach on the pod.
Like, I come on the pod and I'm, like, really?
You know, you've just got to stay in your lane, pick your target, you know, pwn it, just go for it, don't worry about it.
But then when you get in the situation, applying it is so much different, you know?
Yeah.
And so I definitely feel that.
But the other thing about these bigger live hacking events is that, you know, there's so much scope.
In the beginning, you can't really do due diligence on everything to see, like, all right, this is where I should, you know, go hack, because it takes too much time.
So for this event, there's probably 15 applications that I could spend the whole event on in scope for this event, right?
And so really, you just got to pick your one, and you got to stick to it, and you got to do it, right?
But it's also kind of a crapshoot then, because you could just pick the wrong app.
You know, the app that's just not as vulnerable.
And, you know, you do your best to do your due diligence at the beginning, but, you know, that's just kind of how the cards lie sometimes.
So I'm having fun with my app, and as long as I make my little, you know, nut that I need for the month or whatever, then I think it'll be good.
Yeah, yeah, that's awesome.
Yeah, I had a very similar experience where, like, before the event started, before the kickoff calls, I was like, okay, I'm going to focus on this thing, like, specifically.
I'm just going to spend all the time, like, hacking this one thing, and I'm going to find some sick bugs, going to take me some time.
Then, like, two days in, I was already hacking the other target.
I was like, man, like, I need to, like, go hack this other stuff.
Like, ugh, I'm not finding what I want here.
I need to, like, switch it up.
Like, yeah.
This is one of the reasons I think I enjoyed our last little collab that we did together over the previous live hacking event, because I think one of my things is I will actually stick to the target that I commit to, like, and I just, I won't get derailed, won't go look at anything else.
I'll just stick to it.
And I think if I, and I think you have the capability to jump around from different target to target and still find bugs, but I think if I can just direct you, you know, and just, like, no, Joel, we're going to focus on this.
Like, this is the thing.
Like, let's do it right now.
Then I think we had some really cool results.
And so.
That's true.
I've been told this in other aspects of my life as well, that it's, like, I'm, like, a car that's, like, speeding forwards, but I have, like, really bad turning.
And so, like, if somebody could just, like, steer it in the right direction, it's just, like, full speed ahead, but.
Yeah.
Keeping, keeping, keeping the analogy, though, you know, you are moving quicker than most people are, though.
So I think, I think it works for you.
You know, you still get where you're going, you know, even if you're not taking the most efficient path.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all get there in the end, you know.
Yeah.
Cool.
For sure.
All right.
Let's dive into some news, yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
What's on the, first up on the docket?
Okay, so I was scrolling through Twitter this morning.
I literally, like, I woke up, I wake up, like, crazy early.
It's, like, five o'clock in the morning.
I'm, like, open Twitter, and, like, I have this notification that says, like, new tweet from InfoSecAU.
Oh, man.
Here we go.
And, like, for the record, I love Shubs.
I don't have tweet notifications turned on, which means that this is, like, a popular enough tweet that I got sent to me, okay?
Like, by Twitter.
And I open it up, and it's, like, oh, yeah, I was working on this, like, crazy research with ZLZ and Brett Ziet and Reese Elmore.
And, yeah, here's a blog post.
And I, like, open it up, and it's, like, hacking, like, root TLD servers.
And I'm, like, oh, okay, cool.
So they hacked the internet.
Got it.
They did it again.
It's so funny you say that because that's literally the exact same thing that happened to me.
Like, I mean, minus the whole waking up at, you know, crack of dawn thing.
I woke up at 630, rolled over, hit snooze, woke up at 730.
And then I picked up my phone, and Twitter had bumped, you know, to my notification list this amazing, amazing thing.
And I opened it right away and just read through, you know, I was, I was, like, oh, man, like, good morning to me.
And then I see this tweet.
And then, you know, before I know it, I'm halfway through.
My eyes are wide open.
I'm, like, you know, heartbeats racing, you know, following this story that they got on here.
So it's pretty sick.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, I love these little, these posts, because every once in a while, like, there's a, there's this group of people, especially Sam, ZLC, and Zayat, like, those two are.
They're the common denominator across all the different groups, I think.
Yeah.
And generally, it'll be, like, there'll be, like, a couple months, like, things will be just, like, going by, like, nothing's happening.
And then out of nowhere, like, there'll be, like, a five-page blog post that's, like, detailing how they hacked some core infrastructure within, like, the global internet or something.
It'll be, like, we hacked undersea cables.
We hacked TLDs.
We hacked all the car, like, start, like, engine remote start-stop shit.
Like, it's, like, it's crazy.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah, it's crazy.
I mean, we talked about that sort of tendency on episode 17, you know, the live episode that we did in LA.
And it just, some, particularly Sam, has an uncanny ability to just find critical internet infrastructure and, like, destroy it.
So it's kind of nuts.
Yeah.
Like, these, I like to think that I have these same kinds of thought processes, but then they end kind of where I'm, like,
Huh, that's interesting.
I wonder how that works.
And then I just move on.
Yeah.
Or, oh, they don't have a bug bounty program.
Move along.
You know, like, I feel like I'm too, I feel like I'm too focused on that.
Like, I feel like, I don't know.
And it's also a little bit of a ballsy thing.
You know, like, I haven't done a lot of just, let's call it good faith security research, right?
I think that's the term that they use in the, you know, computer fraud or whatever act.
Yes, that is the modified term, yes.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And so, like, I haven't done a lot of good faith security research, you know, just for fear of, you know, crossing boundaries, causing people a nightmare, that sort of thing.
But, you know, every time they drop a blog post about the stuff they've done, you know, I think, man, like, if somebody else had done this, this would have been a nightmare for the whole internet.
And, you know, at this point, Sam and Squad have saved the internet like six times.
So, I have to respect that, you know, whether or not I agree with going out of scope or not.
Yeah, yeah, no, it's true.
I think, like, now we're starting to get into an era where that type of work is a lot more, like, okay and allowed and stuff.
But, you know, five, ten years ago, this wouldn't have been, like, if you did this, there was actual serious risk that something really bad could happen.
And, like, you could just get charged by, like, you know, and, like, sent to jail.
Yeah, you know, like, you know, you're hacking, like, such core infrastructure that this stuff can be taken the wrong way.
But I think we're finally starting to get to a point, and especially with the laws and everything that have changed, that, like, security research, especially ethical, like, white hat security research, is a lot more accepted and mainstream.
And so, you know, coming from that approach, I think Sam, especially with all the experience Sam has, Sam has done this so many times with so many other people.
And I don't mean that in, like, a negative way.
Like, that's just, like, his gem.
And that's cool.
Sam just hacks whatever, man.
Yeah, he sees something interesting.
He's like, I'm going to hack that.
That's, like, it.
You know, once he's going to hack it, he's going to hack it.
And so I think he has figured out the right ways to communicate that with companies in a way that such that he doesn't come across as, like, threatening or, like, anything illegal.
And I think he's even said privately only a handful of times, like, literally, like, a couple of times has it ever even edged towards, like, the case where, like, things would be going negatively in the communications.
And it never actually ended up that way.
It was just kind of like, this is sketchy communications.
Let's just, like, you know, move on and it gets over with.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure, man.
No, I respect that.
And I will confess, I recently succumbed to the temptation and hacked the cool target that I wanted to hack.
And I have not gotten any response back despite following Sam's template.
And I didn't put any, but, you know, the way that, because I hit Sam up, I was like, all right, Sam, like, I did the thing.
How do I tell people about it, right?
And Sam's like, all right, you should do this, this, this.
And so I followed his instructions.
And I really like the way that he approaches it because it's very non-threatening.
It's very professional and, you know, cards on the table forward, you know.
And so I really, I really like that.
We should definitely, we should have him on the pod and to talk about that specific thing.
I'll note that down for a future topic because that is a pretty cool, unique feature of Sam, Sam et al., you know, going after these sort of out of scope things.
And the way that they deal with it, I think, is something that the community could benefit from.
Yeah, for sure.
This was actually reminding me, now that we're thinking about it, we're talking about, like, contacting website owners and stuff.
There is a really interesting repo that popped up on my Twitter feed.
And we'll link this in the show notes.
It's by John Keegan.
And it's called Behind This Website.
And it's essentially a checklist.
It's on GitHub.
And it's a checklist of things that you can go through to try and identify who actually owns a website.
So it's stuff like, are there authors listed?
What is the local time of the website?
Does it have an RSS feed?
Do they have links to, like, Facebook and Twitter?
If so, do they have contact info on the Facebook page?
Here's where you can find it.
All that kind of stuff.
And I think for, like, security research, especially if you're hacking, like, a website that doesn't have a bug bounty program, may not have, like, a security contact or something like that.
Yeah.
This is probably a good way to try and get some of those other direct lines of contact.
Because I know this is something that Sam struggles with.
Like, it's very hit or miss.
Some of the websites that he'll be hacking, like, he'll try and reach out to somebody.
And it's impossible to get through.
He'll have to, like, go to LinkedIn.
He'll have to go to Twitter.
He'll have to hit up, like, random employees who are working at the company on, like, random social media.
So this might be something that's useful if you're not getting a lot of traction with your initial email.
Yeah.
Send it over.
I definitely want to check it out.
And I think, like, I've kind of poked around on, like, LinkedIn and some other places trying to find, you know, the right person to come in contact with.
And I think the other thing is that I don't know, you know, what Sam's LinkedIn presence is.
But I feel like if you had a bigger LinkedIn presence, you know, I feel like that might help because you could just kind of, like, you know, reach out to your network.
And we're all, like, you know, seven degrees away from, like, some obscure person on the other side of the world.
So I'm sure somehow you could get in contact with the right people if you had a big enough presence and sort of a professional network.
Yeah, for sure.
I was actually, I was wondering, the website, you know, we got a little derailed here, but the website that posted this blog post.
It's hackcompute.com.
Yeah, I saw that.
Yeah.
First of all, never heard of them.
And I was looking into it.
And I have a feeling we might be hearing more from this group in the future because they have nothing posted on this blog except for a forward from January, six months ago.
That's, like, talking about how the industry has changed and all this stuff.
And, you know, we, like, you know, now we just hack stuff for, like, good and, you know, how this group will, like, focus on really high impact stuff.
And then six months later, they post this blog about hacking the TLD, CCTLD, you know.
Yeah, I kind of feel like this group of people, you know, Sam, Brett, Reese, and Shubs, they're just like, hey, let's make this, like, cool hacker group and then, like, pwn the internet.
And they're like, cool.
What's the most crazy thing we could go for?
Okay, well, what if we could control every single domain in the whole internet?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And then they just, you know, it takes them, what, T-minus five months?
Not even, probably, because they were probably having this conversation way before that.
Yeah, yeah, 100%.
Super, super cool.
Oh, my gosh, dude, look at this.
If you look at the, if you, I just saw this, you know, if you look at the Telegram communication they were having with this guy about halfway through the hacking EPP servers blog post, it says January 14.
Is when they're having that conversation.
So, what did they post this?
January 18th.
They posted January 15th?
Oh, did they really?
No, but they created their initial forward on January 18th.
Okay, gotcha, gotcha.
So, they, you know, they, yeah, maybe it was the other way around.
Maybe they were just like, oh, what if we hacked the whole internet?
Yeah.
As a cool security group.
As a cool security group, yeah.
So, I'm hoping to see some more stuff from this group, these real heavy hitters.
And I'll be curious if it's just going to be, like, that core group of people.
They're going to branch out and just do, like, just blog posts with anybody who's doing this kind of hacking or what it is.
But, yeah.
It would be interesting to see for sure.
Yeah, definitely give that blog post a read.
It's super consumable.
It's very straightforward.
And it's an awesome example of just the old, outdated, vulnerable infrastructure that's all over the place on the internet.
Yeah, for sure.
So, speaking of consumable blog posts, another banger that Shubs tweeted out is this one that just popped up this morning, actually.
So, I'm really glad we recorded the pod today because, you know, Shubs tweeted, Shubs et al, you know, tweeted the crazy EPP server thing last night.
And then this morning he tweeted this and I'm just like, man, these are, like, right top of the list.
Yeah.
So, this next one we wanted to talk about was a write-up by a group apparently called Summoning.team.
I guess that's the name of the company.
And this is on a couple CVEs that were released earlier this year for VMware vRealize Network Insight.
And this was a really cool vulnerability.
And I just, I love, I love stuff surrounding NGINX configurations after, after my, you know, life and death experience with NGINX configuration files with Sam Erb last year that we presented on at Defcom.
So, I love, I love reading NGINX related stuff.
And as Shubs said in his tweet, you know, this is like a crazy, a crazy cool little twist on NGINX reverse proxies.
So, essentially, the TLDR of this, I don't know, did you get to review it or not?
Yeah, I reviewed some of it.
Oh, nice.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
So, the TLDR of this was, you know, it's a pretty straightforward command injection.
And you actually see this, the procedure that they used to get it was create support bundle.
And this is something that I've actually seen a lot in enterprise software is like, there's normally some sort of weird endpoint somewhere that it allows you to create a bundle for support so that, you know, they can send off all the logs and stuff like that to, you know, the team to provide support for the product.
Yeah.
And, of course, you know, the way that these sort of like dev oriented backend functionalities get implemented is, of course, just calling stuff straight from the command line.
So, you get a pretty textbook command injection there.
But I think the cool part was the NGINX bug.
And it took me a second to sort of realize what was going on here.
But the reverse proxy that they have in place is supposed to be filtering out a specific route, which is this SAS rest to SAS servlet location.
And for the first time I looked at it, I don't know if you had the same thing, Joel, but I was like, man, I feel like this should be really obvious to bypass, but it's not, you know, because they're just like reverse proxy to the same location on the backend.
But what ended up doing it was, you know, this sort of, it's not really an off by slash sort of thing.
It's pretty close to that.
But just abusing the sort of dot functionality in directories and the way that NGINX takes care of that to be able to hit the same endpoint on the backend that you would have only been able to hit via the first little location snippet there.
And so it's kind of hard to explain over audio, but it's a really cool bypass.
So we'll link it down in the show notes and definitely check it out if you enjoy NGINX configuration stuff.
Yeah.
So basically like when you have like NGINX figs, you have these location like routes that basically say like anything under this path or maybe matching this regex should be handled like by this route, like by these rules.
So if apparently this is something new to me, I didn't know this, but yeah, if you put like a dot slash before your path, that's equivalent in routing, it's equivalent to like going to that path, but it gets handled differently by the NGINX config.
So that lets you bypass like the NGINX config rule, but still hit that path and be able to hit the path that you weren't supposed to access with no one.
So crazy.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
I really like it a lot.
Yeah, and it looks like the person behind this blog, by the way, I was looking a little bit in the about section on the summoning team.
And it says that, I don't know if it's a team of people, if it's just this one person, but it says their name is Sina and they're a bone researcher and they link out to their Twitter, Sinsinology.
They are a pwned own participant.
They work on Microsoft MVR.
So yeah, it seems like somebody who knows their stuff and is definitely not their first time around this type of stuff.
So this is pretty dope.
Nice, dude.
That's pretty rad.
I just followed them on Twitter.
Definitely going to try to keep up with that.
I definitely want to at some point participate in pwned own.
Like I think that's just going to be on the bucket list item for a while.
You know, HackerOne keeps us pretty busy with the live hacking events that we run here.
But at some point I may have to be like, you know what?
I'm just going to take the next couple months and focus on pwned own related stuff because that'd be a cool bucket list item, I think.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I have the same goal.
So that's, let's see.
Oh, yeah.
The only other thing I wanted to bring up in the news section for today was literally right before this call again.
So once again, the news is killing it.
I'm glad we decided to record when we did.
Roy from Zoom, the guy that runs the Zoom bug bounty program, tweeted out Zoom's new sort of vulnerability impact scoring system.
And Joel and I were privy to this because we, they're actually, we'd heard about it before through some channels.
But, you know, they just released it.
And essentially, it's a new, it's a replacement for CVSS.
And I don't know, man, what do you think about it?
It's kind of, eh.
This is trying, this is like, you know, they're like, do you know what a bacronym is?
A what?
A bacronym.
A bacronym is like when you, yeah, it's like when you take like, you have an acronym that you want and you come up with words that fit that acronym that describe it, right?
So it's like, you'll see this a lot with like congressional bills and stuff.
Oh, yeah.
They'll have like a fancy like short name for it that's like pronounceable, like a real word or something.
And then each letter stands for some like ridiculously long, yeah.
But it doesn't like perfectly correlate to the concept.
Like definitely started with the acronym and then worked back.
I like that.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
So it's called a bacronym.
This feels like a bacronym for like trying to figure out how you're supposed to codify bounty payments.
You know what I mean?
Like instead of just looking at it and being like, this is this impact and we should be paying this much because it's that bad according to a table.
You're like, all right, we have to like break this down into like, like completely consistent across the board segments that we can then like plug into a uniform system and get like reliable output results back.
And like that's awesome, but that is like, I feel like it's trying to overcomplicate like a solution for a problem that doesn't really exist.
Yeah.
Yeah, man.
I mean, I don't know.
I feel like there is a problem.
Like I feel like CVSS is definitely not amazing, but it's something that we've become used to.
And I think VSS or VISS, which is the thing that they named it.
I don't know.
Just for me as a bug bounty hunter, it increases my risk and my friction for using, you know, for reporting bugs to Zoom because it's like, okay, now I've got to go read this whole spec that you invented.
So, you know, so you've definitely got the upper hand here.
Right.
And, you know, I don't know.
I don't know anything about any of the metrics.
You know, like I don't.
It's not like a small spec either, by the way.
No, it's not.
It's a long spec.
It's very complex.
It's probably as dense or more dense than CVSS itself.
Yeah.
And so, you know, on one hand, I like to see a good stab taken at, you know, CVSS and the current vulnerability, you know, metric system.
But on the other hand, I feel like this misses the mark on the side of simplicity.
You know, maybe this covers, you know, everything that they wanted.
But for me as a bug bounty hunter, my risk just doubled or tripled, you know, to report a bug here.
So I think overall, it will negatively impact their bug bounty program just from a participation perspective.
And then, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I guess we'll see how it plays out.
If more people adopt it, that could not be the case.
But, you know, we'll kind of see.
Yeah.
I mean, I've seen a couple other programs try and do similar stuff to this.
Even when I worked at Uber, Uber tried to do a similar thing to this.
And we found that it was just, like, really, really complicated to try and do it for all bugs.
There were certain things where we could, like, certainly codify the bounties.
Like, generally speaking, XSS was something that you could, like, you know, depending on what type of XSS.
And then maybe there was a modifying factor if it's, like, particularly sensitive or the report shows additional impact or something like that.
But, you know, generally speaking, like, we would be able to pay an XSS the same, like, across the board.
But that's not the case for every kind of bug.
And trying to do that for, like, everything uniformly, every single type of bug within one system is very, very difficult.
Yeah.
So I'll be interested to see how this actually pans out.
I think using this as, like, part of their calculation would be a great idea.
But using it for the whole calculation just leaves a lot of room for, like, oh, the calculator says this.
Even though we don't agree with it, we're going to pay it because the calculator says that.
And that's consistent, right?
And I don't think that is going to land great.
Yeah.
I agree, man.
And who knows?
You know, I think hackers are going to hack.
And, you know, someone will probably read through this whole spec and figure out, okay, how can I, you know, eek a high or crit out of something that I find on a pretty regular basis, you know, with the configuration tenants with the different metrics in this guy.
So, you know, maybe it'll work out in the favor of the hacker.
I just, I just feel pretty.
Yeah.
Being on the hacking side, I feel apprehensive.
Yeah, you just have to figure out how to game the calculator so that you get the highest score possible with the least effort.
And then, yeah, that's what the calculator says it.
That's what the guys, you know, that's when, you know, whenever programs stick very, you know, intensely to, to CVSS, I know a couple people that are, that will just not on a specific, very high paying program that just will hold on to their bugs and figure out like some weird fringe way to affect like integrity, even if it's a confidentiality bug.
And then like, you just get that extra bump, which is like, you know, at that point, it's like 10 grand and you're like, cha-ching.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
It's pretty good.
I see you have a note in here that says, do you ask yourself why on black box testing?
And I was curious what that meant.
Okay.
All right.
Let me, let me explain this.
And there's a tweet going out about this later today.
It'll, it'll land before the pod drops.
But on this, on this live hacking event scope that we're, that we're working on, I've run into a bug or two that really, I decided, I feel like I move too quickly sometimes on these sort of things.
I like, oh, cool, a bug.
And then I like report it.
And then, you know, and, and not that I necessarily move on, but that I'll just like keep searching.
But I think I need to pause for a second.
I really need to put some like CPU cycles into, by that I mean, you know, brain energy into, into like, why did that work?
Like, what does this bug tell me about the mistakes that companies will be making in their infrastructure?
And, and, and, and their coding practices?
And what can I determine about that that might help me find similar bugs?
And, and I just, I don't, you know, I've heard people sort of talk about this before, but I'm not sure I've ever sat down and actually put like five minutes of thought into, all right, well, you know, if this, you know, happens here, then maybe, you know, this is what's happening on the back end.
And just kind of work to do that whole, um, thought progression.
And because I did that this time, I found some interesting stuff.
So I just wanted to see what your thoughts were on that.
Yeah, no, that's really interesting.
Um, I think that's a great approach because oftentimes when something goes wrong, it's a systemic problem.
It doesn't mean that it's like implemented like in one place and it's affecting multiple things.
That could be what it is, but oftentimes it's that like a developer has seen a pattern somewhere else and they're just copying that pattern or maybe, uh, the, you know,
they just literally made like a single one-off mistake and that happens too, where it's only in one spot and it may not be a common issue, but trying to understand what, you know, what led them to make that, that, you know, logical leap or whatever to actually write that error into the code, like trying to figure that out and then play on that, like later down the line, even if it's not within the same field.
So say it's, you find an IDOR through some specific case, you can test that IDOR with the same ID, the same type of ID in other places.
But I would also test that same ID or like method or whatever with other IDs in other places, because it could be that it's not like specific to a user ID.
For example, it could be that it's also working on group IDs or whatever type of IDs exist, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
No, I love that tip.
And I think this is where being in your shoes as a, as someone who reads, you know, large corporation backend code on a regular basis, I think that really helps for mapping out like what, what could possibly be happening and why a specific vulnerability would be in place.
Because like for me, I did like, you know, a year of PHP dev when I was 18 years old at like a startup incubator, you know, and that's the, that's the extent of my, my, you know, knowledge of, of backend writing code processes.
Right.
So I don't have much to lean on there, but I feel like if you, if you have a little bit more of an understanding of how things might be implemented, especially when companies release these, these docs that, that sort of talk about their backend architecture.
Like, and, and, and by the way, I did check, we, we can release who, who's in this life hacking event, this is Zoom and Salesforce.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Um, and, uh, and, you know, I'll, I'll just call, I'll just give them a shout out right away.
Salesforce, um, you know, they, they dropped some really, really nice, um, public documentation.
They put it all in a doc for us during this event and it made it so much easier to understand what's happening, um, you know, in the backend.
And, and I, I kind of read through a bunch of that and, um, I think when I found bugs and I started correlating it to the way that their infrastructure is designed, things started to become a little bit more clear.
And, uh, that's the kind of stuff you like to, to have when you're trying to find all these bugs.
So.
Yeah, for sure.
I mean, some of these companies have way better documentation than others.
Um, you know, Salesforce, uh, are we allowed to say specifically what the like things within it are?
Yeah, I, I, I wouldn't, I wouldn't.
Okay.
So you, uh, you can imagine what I'm talking about here, but one of them has pretty good documentation, but then a lot of the endpoints that I'll be looking at, that seem fairly basic.
I'll look it up and I'll expect to find docs and there's nothing for it.
Yeah.
So, so it really varies, but I, that's also like one of the awesome things is if a company has extensive documentation, read through it and try and find things that are inconsistent or sound like weird functionality, because it might be something that's vulnerable by design that you can exploit to your advantage.
Or it might just be something that doesn't line up with how it's actually behaving in the real world.
And then that's a perfect use case where you can say, Hey, the docs say it should be behaving this way.
It's actually not.
It should be behaving this way.
Yeah.
The vulnerable, the vulnerable by design thing sort of just, I don't know, man, I, I, I've gotten burned on that a couple of times because there are some really poor architecting decisions happening at like a very large level with some of these big companies that we're hacking on all the time.
Right.
And, and I, as I try to point some of these out, they're like, yeah, that's what we told the dev team when they wrote the project.
So internal dupe, but I'm like, okay, but you still let them make the product, you know, like, I don't know.
Maybe security just doesn't have enough sway in these larger corporations, but you know, you hate to see stuff like that.
Cause it, I mean, it puts users at so much risk and it also pisses off bug bounty hunters.
Yeah.
It's like a weird state cause some of, some of it is accepted risk.
It's like, you know, they know that this is an issue, but it's not like an issue that they consider to be an issue.
So they're, it's like, you know, if it becomes public, then that doesn't really matter to them and maybe they'll change it then.
But you know, a lot of the time there's just not enough effort to.
And accepted risk is one thing, but like, and, and if they say that, then that's fine.
And I'm going to, I'm going to blog about it, you know, because at least some of the stuff that I'm, that I'm thinking of right now, you know, you can see me, Joel.
Justin's holding himself back.
He's like, his blood pressure is 180 over 30.
You know, like, yeah.
And so, oh man, my heart's going to explode, Joel.
But yeah, you know, if they, if they, I think the users need to be, the company can accept the risk, but users need to be able to make an informed decision about, you know,
if they accept that risk when utilizing a certain service provider.
And I think that's where a little bit of a disconnect comes because I can write my blog all I want.
And, you know, as a, you know, medium-sized player in the security world, maybe, you know, 50,000 people or 100,000 people will read it or something like that on a good day.
But, you know, that doesn't, that information is not trickling all the way down to the users that are making the decision to use that service provider on a, on a, you know, daily, weekly basis.
And so, I don't know, there's a little bit of a disconnect there.
This is the ramblings of a frustrated security researcher, but yeah, there's not a really great solution out there in, in our current, you know, state.
And that is what it is.
Yeah, cool.
All right.
You want to hit the main topic for this episode?
Yeah, man.
I think that was the longest news segment we've ever done.
Like, and it was news plus like, you know, bug bounty revelations or whatever.
But yeah, yeah, but we'll keep it a little tight today because, you know, we're both in the live hacking event and just kind of chilling, you know, on pod stuff and focusing on hacking stuff.
But the thing that we wanted to talk about today was doing some, I don't know, just dropping some cool physical setup stuff that we've got.
I've got a pretty cool hacking setup from my perspective, but I realized recently, you know, the perspective you're getting in the background might need some work.
Because if you look at like Stalk and Jay Haddix and some of the other guys, like, you know, when you hop on a video call with them, it's like, boom, you know, like in their, like in their hacker den with the lights coming on, you know, and like cool things spinning in the background.
And so I think I need to kind of level up on that front.
I know me too.
I like I see some of those like Naham as well.
He has like, oh yeah, Naham Singh as well.
You know, all these people have like really amazing like backgrounds that are like set up and like designed.
He had like little like trinkets and stuff that like fill the space.
And I just got like 15 posters behind me.
Same bro.
Same.
Yeah.
I ought to hit Stoke up because I want to say I saw something somewhere about someone flying Stoke out somewhere to help them design their sort of like hacker setup, you know?
And unfortunately Stoke doesn't make it over to the East Coast very often, but maybe I'll do like a virtual consulting session with him and be like, Stoke, how do I make this cool?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
So to that end, you know, basically as people who spend all day at a computer and at a desk, like generally speaking, we think it's very worthwhile to put your money where your butt is.
And so that's like your keyboard, your mouse, your monitors, your desk, your chair, your environment that you're working in, like all that stuff.
Like, you know, if it's where you're spending eight plus hours a day, a third of your life, then you should probably make an investment, right?
It's just like a bed, right?
Buy a good mattress.
Buy good.
You know, if you're walking a lot, buy good shoes.
If you're sitting a lot, buy a good chair.
If you're using your computer a lot, buy a good computer.
Yeah, no, for sure, man.
I totally agree.
And I had a little, you know, anecdote that I wanted to share on this behalf.
You know, when I was in college, I was pretty busy.
I worked at a, I interned at a big company, Dominion Energy in Richmond.
And so I was biking back and forth from Dominion to my school, you know, on a regular basis.
So I was, I was staying, you know, pretty active and I graduated and I got my first hacking job.
And I feel like, you know, a year and a half, two years just kind of blew by.
And then I remember sitting at my apartment, you know, and realizing like, man, I'm not very active right now.
Like, why am I, why do I have, what is this fat that's on the lower side of my bed?
You know, like, what is going on here?
And I was like, you know what, you know, it's fine.
I'm probably not too far along.
Let me just go like hit the treadmill for a little bit.
And so I hit the treadmill and I ran like, you know, 0.25 miles and I was like, you know, I was dying.
And so it's like, yeah.
And I just also, you know, I realized my posture had sort of changed from staying at the desk just for, just from like a year and a half.
And I think I was just kind of blinded by, you know, the new career, the new setup, you know, sort of grinding on book bounty and hacking stuff at the time.
And I totally put out the window, you know, the personal fitness and the posture and that sort of thing.
Investments that needed to be made to save me some time, you know, and energy.
And, and since then, you know, I've, I've remediated a lot of those issues and we can talk about some of the stuff that I've done to do that today.
But I just wanted to, you know, say this for anyone listening that kind of finds himself in that similar scenario.
The longer you wait on this, the harder it gets, right?
I don't care if you've been doing this for 10 years.
If you do it for 15 years, if you do it for 11 years, you do it for 10 years and six months, it's going to be harder than it was at 10 years, right?
So like, you know, you need to make those lifestyle changes ASAP and, and it doesn't have to be drastic, but it should be intentional, I think, because it's all too easy to kind of let it go and then have it become unmanageable.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, have you always been like a computer person, like sitting and like using computers growing up?
Oh, hell yeah, dude.
Okay.
Yeah.
I, I started really getting into computers when I was like 10.
Yeah, same.
Okay.
So I don't know if it's similar for you, but like I'm in my mid twenties, I have lower back pain already, like just from sitting all day.
Like, you know, if I sit too much or if I'm hunched over at my desk for like, even for like one day, if I have like a long day where I'm particularly like heads down and I'm like bent over like my back, I'll feel it for sure.
And I have to do like certain stretches and stuff to like stretch out my lower back.
Yeah.
I don't know, man.
I haven't had lower, lower back quite as much.
Um, but I do notice that my posture, you know, suffers for sure.
Like I definitely have, you know, computer neck sometimes, you know, and I'm like got my neck forwarded, that sort of thing.
And I've always been, you know, I, I think I sort of shouted Corbin out on the pod when he came on, but like, you know, if you look at any of the, uh, the hack one media, you know, Corbin's a good looking guy for sure.
So there's that, that helps as well.
But I think he shows up in a lot of hacker one photos because he's just got such a, like, he's got good posture.
He's got a good build, you know, like in any of the, yeah, he doesn't have the gamer neck, you know, and it's because he's putting in the reps at the gym, man.
I've talked to him about that.
I was like, you know, what kind of exercises are you doing and stuff like that?
And he, he attributes a lot of that to deadlift and, and stuff like that.
So I don't know, you know, I do deadlift.
Do you, do you deadlift?
I used to a little bit.
Honestly, my main concern is injuring myself.
Um, yeah.
Like I think if I was going to do, I was going to talk about this.
So yeah, like doing workouts and stuff that are specific to your work environment is something that's super helpful, right?
Like again, you sit all day, do like ab core, like lower back workouts and stuff like that.
That's going to build those muscles because inherently by sitting and not using them, those muscles aren't getting worked and they're not going to be as strong as the rest of your muscles.
Right.
We're going to have like, you know, pretty like good muscles and like our arms and whatever from like typing and like using, you know, our eyes.
We're not going to get eye strain to the same effect and all that kind of stuff.
But like, you know, the other areas are where it's going to suffer.
So I think targeting those areas and it doesn't have to be deadlifts.
You can do like there's other, you know, squats and you can do like, uh, like presses and whatever.
Like, you know, there's, there's lots of stuff that you can do to build those, those muscles.
You've got a standing desk, right, Joel?
I do.
Yeah.
I should actually fucking use it.
I was going to say, like, I feel like every time I record the pod, whenever I'm recording the pod, you know, there's just a certain amount of energy that I want to put into it.
And I just feel like that matches standing way better than sitting.
So like 90% of the time when we're recording the pod, I'm standing at my desk.
And I do, I stand at my desk maybe like, maybe like once or twice a day, you know, normally when I'm just doing hacking and just working on normal stuff.
You see, dude, that, that, that actually looks, that looks better with your background too.
You know, if you get that lamp out of there though, and you just kind of get it locked in, you've actually got a pretty good setup, I think.
That works well.
Maybe I should be standing more.
How tall are the ceilings in your, in your room?
Uh, they're eight feet, I think.
The standard height?
Yeah.
Just normal eight feet?
Nice.
Now that, that looks good.
Sorry, sorry for you people.
No, I'm not, I'm not tall enough.
Yeah, it doesn't hit the top.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, so, I mean, what, I, I've, for me, I use, um, uplift desks and I think they're great, man.
It's worth it.
Your uplift as well?
Yep.
Yeah.
I think, uh, I think it's really nice.
And I, I did want to do a shout out to Mariah here.
Um, you know, I, uh, I, I have an L uplift desk, so I, I bought, you know, I've had a, I bought
one of their, their fully designed products and had it sent to me, but Mariah actually
just bought the, she has an uplift desk as well.
And she just bought the legs and she went to home Depot and got a butcher block top and oiled
it up and like, you know, got it looking pretty.
And then I just, you know, we just screwed it on top of the, yeah.
And it looks super good.
Um, way better than mine, uh, that I just bought directly from uplift.
So, um, that's a really good opportunity as well.
And I think it only costs her like 150 bucks total.
Yeah.
So it really depends on the size that you're going for, um, the legs, like just buying the
legs, like independently, like that's like a great solution, especially maybe you already
have a desk or a desktop that you like, and you can take it off.
Um, for me, I wanted a huge desk.
Like I like having a lot of space on my desk.
I keep a lot of stuff on my desk.
I have like speakers and monitors and my PC is on my desk and all that kind of stuff.
So, um, I like having like as much space as I could when I was looking at standing
desk, uplift desk had the largest, uh, standing desk that I could find.
And I think it's like 84 inches or something long.
It's like, it's, it's huge.
Yeah.
So it's great.
Like I have much more space than I would ever need.
Um, and the top, you know, if you buy the top directly from them, like finding a piece
of, you know, hardwood material or something like that, that, that that's that large to get
shipped to you is about the same price and hard to find.
So, um, I ended up just getting the top with them, but I think,
did you get an L or did you know, no, I have a fully straight one.
I have a friend who has, um, like the L shape with like, it's a long portion and they have
a shorter, like L portion.
Um, and I had really thought about that, but, uh, uh, it's, it really depends on the room.
Like that, that's what I found.
I moved with this desk, uh, one or two times and depending on what your office layout is,
is going to depend on whether or not that desk is really going to work in the room.
So I didn't want to have to keep like buying rebuying desks and all that kind of stuff.
So I just stuck stuck with like a straight long desk.
Um, but I will probably eventually replace the replace this and I'm not sure if I'll do the same.
I've got like the, I've got like the five by four, I think is, is what it, and I'm not gonna lie.
It's a little tight.
I think, you know, I, I think it could be, and it fits my room perfectly.
So I'm, I'm glad I bought it.
Um, and I'm not planning on moving much.
I think maybe I'll move, you know, one or two times in my, in the rest of my life, probably.
Yeah.
Um, and so I'm, I didn't, you know, I decided to buy the desk for this space.
Um, but yeah, I think, I think next time I w I would go with a six.
No, this is actually a six.
This is a six by, this is a six by four.
Uh, I think, I think next time I would go a little bit bigger though,
because it does help to have that additional room over to the side.
And especially when you've got an L shape you're and I'm, and I've got my monitor set up,
which I'll talk about in a second, which I absolutely love by the way.
Um, you know, it takes up a good chunk of the desk and I need some more, some workspace as well.
Like for example, when we were doing the hardware hacking stuff, I had to set up this little table,
you know, behind me here to get, to get the hardware hacking stuff at a good spot.
Because if I was trying to do it on this table, everything just got too crowded.
Yeah.
Well, that's actually a tip that, that I didn't write it down, but I think that's a good one.
I have, um, let me see if I can hold this up.
Yeah.
So I have this, uh, I have this like portable table, it's got a little knob here.
So you can basically, you can raise and lower it as you want.
And it's, it's on wheels.
It's on these casters.
And essentially I keep it underneath my desk all the time.
And then if I ever need extra space, I just wheel it out.
I raise it up to the height I want, lock it, portable table.
Good to go.
You can lock the wheels if you want.
And I have one or two of those.
Like I keep one of them in my office.
I keep another one like somewhere else in the house.
But when I'm doing like the hardware hacking stuff, for example, even I don't have enough
room on my desk for, you know, all that hard, like all the, all the tools and stuff.
Mr. Seven foot desk over here doesn't have enough room on his desk.
That's great.
So even with my seven foot desk, I don't have enough, I don't have enough room for it.
So I like having those extra portable, like flexible spaces.
And yeah, I actually have another one right back here.
I don't know if that's in frame.
Yeah, I can see it.
Yeah.
But yeah, that also is like, just sort of like a portable tabletop that I can pull out.
I use it for like eating.
I'll use it for various things, but having that available is awesome.
Do the wheels lock on it?
This one's not on wheels, but the other one does.
Yeah.
It has locking wheels.
That's cool.
I hadn't really thought about getting a little side table like that.
That's, that's, you know, flexible for the space.
That's, that's not a bad idea.
Yeah.
And it's sort of like flexible, like, you know, tabletop space is really useful so that
you don't have to like reorganize your desk if you want to do something big.
Yeah, for sure.
Okay, cool.
So dude, I just, I, yeah, let's talk monitors because I'm, I just, you know,
I feel like most people don't realize that like you're in front
of a fucking space station, like.
Dude, I am, man.
And it's so freaking great.
It's like, this is literally a childhood dream fulfilled.
Okay.
So let me, let me lay this out for you.
So like I mentioned, I've been into computers since I was like, you know, 10, 12, that,
that sort of range.
Right.
And, uh, I have pretty, you know, I don't have a great memory of my like childhood.
It's just all kind of like, yeah, yeah, that was pretty good.
So especially timelines, you know, it wasn't great.
So it's like somewhere back in the, in most of the time that I
can remember, I was in love with computers, but I do remember the point when I became
in love with computers.
And, uh, I've talked about this on the pod before, but it was just one time
this guy from my church came over and he typed into a, you know, black command line box and
fixed the internet.
So I could play my games.
And I was like, dude, that was really cool.
I got to learn how to do that.
So anyway, I, you know, I'd see him every Sunday because we were going to church every Sunday.
And so I'd start asking him, Hey, you know, how can I learn about this?
Bloody, bloody, blah.
And being the awesome guy that he is, he like brought me to his work, which was a university.
Uh, the university that I ended up going to, by the way.
Um, and, uh, and he was like, check out like the setup.
Right.
So I walk into his office and you know, he's like a sys admin or something like that.
I think he's higher up now, but, and the guy has six monitors and it's like, you know,
three on the top, three on the bottom, just like massive array.
There's like graphs going off on all of them.
He's like monitoring this and that, and the other thing.
And I was like, dude, this is sick.
And from that moment on, I was like, I know someday I'm going to have that.
I got to set it up.
And then finally, when we moved back from Japan, I'm like, all right,
I might actually stay in this house for more than a year,
which we hadn't done since I was like 17 at that point.
Um, and, and so I invested and I bought a, uh, and right,
right as I was getting ready to build the setup, dude, I went to,
do you guys have like the re-store near you?
Do you know what that is?
Re-store.
The re-store.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, like the furniture store?
The habitat for humanity thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So dude, I, you know, most people, I think that listen to the pod,
know I do real estate stuff on the side.
So I was going to the, the re-store to, to get some stuff for my real estate projects.
And I walk in there and I see like 12, um, 27 inch 4k HP monitors sitting there.
I'm like, what the heck?
And I walk over there and they're 40 bucks each.
Dude.
Dude, these are $400 monitors.
They're selling for $40.
So I said, I run over to the desk.
I'm like, I, I, I, I'm buying all of those and I just slammed my wallet down on the counter.
And I'm like, I, I'm buying all of those.
And he's like, okay, all right.
You know, we'll get someone to help you move them to your car.
This is the real version of the, of the fry.
Shut up and take my money.
Dude, just take it, shut up and take my money, man.
Because he was like, oh, I was so happy.
And so, you know, I walk out of there.
So some of them weren't 4k or whatever.
So I was like, you know, we'll, we'll leave those.
Uh, you know, but, um, you know, I, I think I ended up getting like seven or eight
27 inch 4k monitors, man.
And I was thrilled.
So what I'm looking at right now is I've got an up uplift sort of monitor mount setup.
I've got four 27 inch monitors, 4k monitors in a square.
And, and I, you know, I realized after I got this, I was like, man, I don't,
I don't have a computer that can, that can handle 420.
So I ended up having to buy this crazy computer that we'll talk about later.
But, um, I finally got it set up and it's like, I have full vision of all of them.
And man, does it help with testing?
Because, you know, you can just segment your different accounts to a different monitor.
And it's like, man, it's so much easier to keep your session straight.
So yeah, I, I really, I think it's really, really great for a bug bounty hunter.
Nice.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I am nothing close to that.
I have, I have, he says, I am nothing.
I have nothing like it.
No, not like I'm like.
In my presence.
Yes.
I'm like an elementary school child compared to Justin's setup.
I have two 1440p monitors.
They're both, they're both 27 inches.
Nice.
It's a good number, man.
27 feels good.
Yeah.
One's a 75 Hertz.
The other one is 244 Hertz.
The main, like my main one in front of me is the 244 Hertz.
So it's like a really nice, like, you can do like gaming and it's like super high refresh rate.
So it looks great.
It's IPS.
So it has really accurate colors, all that kind of stuff.
So that's like my main, like straight, straight on monitor.
And then to my side, I have just for like that, that's the 75 Hertz for everything else.
Then I also, uh, it's not really a monitor, but it's like my laptop.
I, I have, it's, it's like a monitor arm, kind of like what I use for, for my microphone here.
It's like a pneumatic arm, but on the end of it, it has a flat laptop plate that I can
just put my laptop on and it just holds my laptop in the air and it's mounted to my desk.
So if I move my desk up, laptop comes with me.
If I move my desk down, laptop comes with me.
All the cables and everything are like tethered to this.
I can just like pull it closer to me.
If I want, I can move it further away, just on an arm.
It just floats there.
You use a Mac, right?
Yep.
So, so I mean, when you, do you have, how do you mount that into your setup?
Do you have like a mounting station or is there like just single cord or what?
Yeah.
So depending on what I'm doing, I'll use like, um, a hub for the most part.
I don't have to plug like so much stuff in my router is like right here.
So I get like crazy fast speeds over wifi as it is.
So I really don't need to be plugged in over ethernet.
But if I do, I have a switch right behind my PC, which is right next to it.
And I can just plug it in.
I have like a ethernet cable.
That's just not plugged in.
It's just right here.
And I can, I can just plug it in if I need to, um, behind my monitor.
I have like a clamshell dock because I have two laptops.
Actually, I have a work laptop, my personal laptop.
So it has two slots and then that will plug into my main monitor.
So it's a little bit of a complex setup.
What is a clamshell?
What is that?
Oh, he's gonna, he's gonna try to go get it, man.
I'm gonna get it.
Here we go.
It's this.
I actually 3D printed this.
I designed and 3D printed this.
No way, dude.
Yeah.
So this, it's just, it holds two laptops like this.
You just slot them in, you know, um, and then they just like sit on their edge and when they're
plugged in, they'll still work and stuff, but you don't have to have them open.
Um, so I have it set up so that if I want to use a laptop on my monitor setup, I'll put it in clamshell plug.
I'll just like put it in my stand.
I'll plug in an HDMI cable.
I have a button on my stream deck, uh, which I use to set my PC to only display on the secondary monitor.
Okay.
This is like, it's a little hacky.
But basically like windows, you can have it mirror or extend or display only on one or only on the other.
Right.
So I tell it, okay, only display on one monitor.
Yeah.
My mom, the main monitor in front of me then goes, oh, there's no input on DVI.
I'm going to fall back to whatever has an input, which is the laptop that's plugged in on HDMI.
And then that is, yes.
And then I have this piece of software.
It's amazing.
It's by a company called, um, Simless and it's called Synergy.
Uh, it's been around for a while.
It's basically a software KVM and it allows me to configure all of my computers with like a client
server thing.
The server runs on my PC and then I have a client on my laptops and I can
seamlessly move my mouse and keyboard across screens to different computers.
It'll share my clipboard.
Does it work that well though?
Oh, it's, it's instant.
Like there's no latency.
No, nothing.
I've, I've used this for like years and it's yeah.
No way.
Yeah, it's amazing.
That's, that's pretty freaking cool.
Yeah.
I use it on, on the daily basis.
Like I have, I don't even notice it.
Like every once in a while, if there's like network stuff going on internally,
then I'll have like maybe like a, a jump or something on the mouse.
But like it's generally latency-less.
Wow.
I can use the same mouse and keyboard across everything.
Let me just, let me just confirm this here.
So you've got two laptops, your work laptop and your, and your personal laptop.
And then you've got a desktop computer.
Yep.
And that runs Windows.
Okay.
And so you run Synergy on the desktop computer.
You have Synergy running on your client, running on your laptops.
And that allows you to, you know, sort of pull the display onto your, your desktop.
And then you can just kind of seamlessly jump between all of these.
Yeah.
So basically I can use the same keyboard and mouse from my PC.
Wow.
I can even do like rebindings and stuff.
So for example, like Mac uses command, right?
So I have Synergy set up to automatically rebind my like command key and my option keys,
such that I don't have to change like my hand position on my keyboard when I cross OS.
So if I do like control C or whatever, it's in the same spot as it would be on a Mac.
And I just, my brain just does the back and forth.
Um, so yeah, that's what I use.
I just use one keyboard and mouse from my PC across to my other devices.
And then I use my same two monitors.
If I ever want to show a laptop, I'll just plug it into the main monitor,
cut my PC over to a single screen, and then I can still use my PC on the secondary monitor.
And I can just move my mouse back and forth, even across to my laptop that's on the stand here.
Wow.
Dang, dude, that's, that's pretty sick that I, I've always wanted sort of like that
Synergy sort of set up to work, you know, across multiple different computers and having one
mouse, but I haven't really ever gotten anything to work that well.
So I'll have to check out Synergy.
Yeah, Synergy is pretty solid.
I've been using it for a number of years now.
I tried a couple other different pieces of software.
I think there's an open source version of it somewhere as well.
That's like not terrible.
But yeah, this, this one has been pretty much the best one that I've, that I've found and
the most consistent in terms of like performance and usability and all that kind of stuff.
So I have in the notes as well.
You have a capture card, don't you, that you use for some sort of what you do with that?
Yeah.
So one, I bought a capture card for like playing games or something.
Honestly, the biggest advantage that I found with it is that a capture card is essentially
a software display, right?
So if you download the capture software and you have a capture card plugged in, it has an HDMI input
that you can use.
And normally it would, you can like record off of it or display it in your stream or whatever
you're going to do with it.
But you can also just open the software and you can display whatever's going on the input.
So I'll take a Raspberry Pi.
If I need to see something on the display, I'll plug it in.
Or if I need to debug something with a, with a temporary display, I'll just plug it into my,
my capture card and then I'll just pull the software up and I don't have to have
like an extra monitor or something that, that I have lying around that I use just for those things.
Yeah, that's, that's that right there.
That's my extra monitor that I use to plug in my Raspberry Pi.
That's pretty sick, dude.
Actually, I, especially for that specific, you know, circumstance that you talked about where
you're trying to have the Raspberry Pi display that that's something that I've been like,
ah, man, I like, especially with the, with the monitor mounts that I've got,
I'm putting my hand right in front of my, my webcam here, especially with the monitor
mounts that I've got up, like, it's such a pain in the ass to like get behind it and plug in stuff.
And so, uh, you know, I just, I'm using this other, one of my other $40, you know,
4k, uh, monitors that I've got, but I think a capture card would be a really nice addition.
And I actually think, cause Mariah was doing streaming for a while and, and, um,
I think we've got one somewhere.
So I ought to go see if I can track that down and try to use it to do stuff like that.
Cause that'd be really handy to have it all in one spot.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, keyboard and mouse, uh, I use a custom keyboard.
Uh, Joel, I could feel, I knew you were a keyboard junkie.
Yes, I'm a keyboard junkie.
Hold on.
I'll give you a little sound test here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh dude.
It's like, it's like ASMR right there.
Like that.
Uh, yeah, pretty good.
So yeah, it's called a Vega.
Um, they're like impossible to get, but I have a friend who had one and I got it for like crazy
cheap.
So anybody who knows keyboards will probably be like losing their mind, but yes, I have a Vega.
Um, it's all white.
And, uh, for my mouse, I use, uh, the, uh, the G pro super lights.
It's like super, super crazy lightweight.
Um, the main reason I really liked that is because it has this.
You like that?
Yes.
The main thing I like is that it has this little puck here and, uh, this puck is called, um, light
speed and essentially Logitech has a software.
Uh, and I bought into this a little while ago.
They have a mouse pad that has like a, a coil inside of it.
And that coil communicates with, uh, with this little puck here to charge your mouse wirelessly
through the mouse pad.
So I never, ever plugged my mouse in.
It's fully wireless and it has sub one millisecond response time.
Cause it was made for gaming hitting me.
It uses like a 2.4 gigahertz receiver.
And, uh, damn Joel, you have the coolest shit, man.
I swear.
Like, yeah.
So I used to have like a heavier, like gaming.
I, it was like a G 903 or something.
I think, I think it's what it was.
And that was pretty good for a while, but it had like extra buttons.
And it just was like heavier than I wanted.
And I found out that the super light has support for the little charging puck.
And I already had the mouse pad and I wanted to keep that.
Cause I don't like plugging stuff in.
So yeah, I've been using that and that's been amazing.
Dude.
It's so funny.
Like I, for some reason, literally every time my mouse dies, it's, I'm in a League of
Legends game, like, like without fail.
And I'm like in the middle of a team, you know, team battle.
And like, all of a sudden it's like, oh, I can't, I can't move.
Like help.
That's terrible.
I saw, I saw you had one of these.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
So that's my, this was my main mouse for a long time.
For those of you actually listening to our podcast, it's the Logitech MX Master 3 is
the one I use.
Yeah.
So I've got the original, this is the first version, but yeah, I love my MX Master as like
a daily, like comfort, like just daily driver mouse.
If you don't care about like lightweight mouse and any of that, like wireless charging and
all that kind of stuff.
MX Master is such a good, such a good mouse.
I have the MX Anywhere as well, which is their like mini MX mouse for like travel.
Yeah.
And that one's also awesome.
Dude.
I just, I love the scroll bar on this guy.
Like, oh yeah.
That it can unlock.
It's so nice.
And it's, it's got like, really like spin it if you really want to.
And then you can also push on it.
And then it's got like a nice click.
Infinite scroll.
It's great.
I love it.
Yeah.
It's, it's real good.
So I really like this guy.
I, I do have an ergonomic mouse as well.
One that kind of is upright and you can kind of hold it like that.
I think it's called a vertical mouse.
Yeah.
Vertical mouse.
And it, and it's like pretty good, but I actually haven't felt any wrist issues yet.
I say that into my wrist.
Like, I don't know if you can hear it.
It's cracking.
It's like, it's like cracking like crazy.
Um, but you know, man, this is kind of enlightening actually.
Maybe I should, uh, but you know, I could never really get used to it.
And it's such a pain when you're trying to like, you know, get, do your job.
And then you've just got like a bunch of needless friction,
you know, that's derailing your thought process.
So I always just kind of reverted back to the MX master.
Cause it's, it's really handy.
Yeah, for sure.
For something like that.
I think it's really just like, what's your personal preference?
The MX master is really handy.
Uh, man.
I almost missed that.
Oh God.
You're welcome.
You know, I thought you'd want to, I thought you'd want to know.
Okay.
Yeah.
As I was saying before I got dad joked out of existence.
Um, yeah.
Mice are really, it's really personal preference.
It's up to you.
Like what feels comfortable.
So like, I know people who have like wrist problems and they swear by those like vertical
mice or like the ergonomic ball mice or that kind of stuff.
And, um, you know, for me, I just, uh, if it feels good, I don't think about it too much.
And, uh, you know, it is what it is.
Um, for sure.
Okay.
So we're, we're already at the hour mark here.
Um, wanted to cover a couple of things.
So I want to talk about, we're going to eliminate the rest of the things on the list here, but I think
we should talk about our computer setup, our chairs, and then, um, what was the, oh yeah.
I wanted to talk about my, my newest little Chromebook, my little Chromebook setup.
Oh, your Chromebook.
Oh, cool, cool.
Yeah.
So actually I'll do that now.
It's right here.
Actually it's an Acer.
What is it?
That guy right there.
It's an Acer R841T series.
Um, and I think it's got like, you know, like eight gigs of Ram or something like that.
It was only like, I want to say 600 bucks, um, extremely lightweight, you know, two pounds.
Um, and, uh, you know, it doesn't have a ton of Ram.
Um, but you know, it kind of gets the job done.
And, uh, it's a 13 inch, is it a 13 inch?
It might be a, it might be an 11 inch.
So some, somewhere in that range, I feel like it's very portable, you know, and that's kind
of how I wanted to be able to, to, you know, to feel when I was using it.
I've wanted to be able to just throw it in my little mini backpack, my little explorer
backpack that I've got and feel like it's not even there and then pull it out when I need it.
Um, to just do some quick typing for content creation or even for hacking.
And I, I brought it on a, um, on a trip with me to Maine to see Mariah's family.
And, um, and it worked great for super lightweight hacking, you know, like in the evenings we were
sitting around like watching a show or something.
And I was like, yeah, you know, maybe I'll just fiddle around with something.
And I powered up zero tier, um, for your recommendation connected back to my home network.
And I had, uh, you know, a Kaido instance running on my, my PC at home.
Nice.
And I used a zero tier, um, and you know, Kaido's remote sort of feature to connect into that.
I could proxy all my traffic through it and it was really, really nice.
It worked really well.
And I could do all of my, all of my sort of basic testing that I want to do, you know,
at, at, at a basic level, nothing crazy.
Um, you know, from the, from the Chromebook and I didn't have to lug around my big, you know,
eight pound laptop that I normally have to use to use burp.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Are you running anything like custom on it or is it just the stock OS?
Well, um, Chromebook added support for Linux.
So, um, you can, you, you literally, you know, just kind of go in there and just like turn on Linux
and then you've got like a Linux command line.
It's they still don't have like key, key bindings, which is kind of crazy to me.
So I couldn't like, I couldn't, I normally like to hit, like, you know, I have my open a terminal
bound to like windows key enter on my main computer.
Right.
And so I can just boom.
And now I'm in the terminal, you know, bam, bam, bam.
And, uh, and it takes like two or three, I guess, key strokes on the, on the device to
get it to open up the terminal.
But once it's in, it's pretty much like WSL, you know, it's, it's running a little internal
Docker container that runs Linux and, and it's pretty, pretty functional.
Um, and I was actually even, I was just kind of playing around with it.
I was able to install Kaido on the device itself, actually.
Yeah.
I was going to ask, did you just proxy directly to your Kaido
IP at home or like, what did you, I proxied through my Kaido IP at home primarily, but
I also at one point, um, installed Kaido on the device and started using it there, but it
got a little overrun, um, even with Kaido, you know, being as efficient as it is, um, it
got a little overrun with that.
So I reverted back to the, you know, the setup from before of just kind of having it open
as a tab in my browser.
Cool.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I've, I've always, I've always thought about doing like a Chromebook.
I'm running an old Intel 2018 MacBook, but, um, my,
my, my work laptop is an M one and, um, I think for my next, my next laptop, I'll probably
go with the Apple Silicon, uh, either, either I'm actually thinking about maybe a MacBook air
because the MacBook air stats, first of all, they're way cheaper, but also the, they have
an M two and the newest MacBook air.
And it's started to like, yeah, like the cheap one, the M one 13 inch starts at a thousand
bucks, starts at nine 99.
And then like, even the 15 inch brand new M two starts at like 1200, 1300.
So, wow.
That's not bad.
It's not like that bad because of the price is so much lower with the Apple Silicon.
And those chips are insane.
They're like, they're workhorses.
They use like no battery.
They're crazy, crazy quick.
Um, I have basically no complaints except for some of the very, very like edge case,
weird x86, 64 emulation stuff that comes with Rosetta too.
Uh, but you can, you can look up that stuff if you're curious about that.
Yeah, no, I was kind of, so I held off on buying the setup for a while.
Cause it was like, ah, I really kind of want to wait.
Well, first of all, like I'm pretty anti Apple to be perfectly honest.
And it's not necessarily founded.
Like, I feel like there are a lot of, you know, respected hackers and technologists, you know,
yourself included that use Apple as their primary, you know, system.
And that's, that's fine.
It's just not for me.
Like I just, I just, I don't like the feel, you know, the branding, I don't know.
So I've, I've been kind of waiting for people to come out with a competitor to the M one.
Cause I, I love the idea of, you know, you know, using a system like that, you know,
so efficient and so, you know, battery, uh, efficient.
Um, but they're just not doing it, you know, and it's just not happening.
And, you know, Apple's already releasing M two and, and, you know, there's not even a
competitor to the M one out there.
Yeah.
And I'm like, come on guys, like get it together.
So anyway, at some point I was just like, you know, it's great.
It's 600 bucks.
I'm not going to like, you know, it's definitely worth it to have something
light and portable with me all the time and reduce that friction to, you know, simple hacking
and content creation.
So I went ahead and bought it, but I'm definitely going to keep my eye out for, you know, an arm
based, uh, you know, PC that will come out in the, in the near future.
Yeah, for sure.
Cool.
Um, all right, let's talk about chairs real quick.
This is, uh, I mean, this one's super easy.
I think chairs, I see you have a DX racer.
I don't know what your take is on that, but, but, uh, my take is Herman Miller or bust.
Um, I had an air on for probably about seven years and then I switched over to a Herman Miller
and body, uh, which is like a better, I guess, in my opinion, better version.
It's got better back support and stuff.
Um, also by Herman Miller and that, uh, I've been on that one for maybe six months now.
And, uh, yeah, that one's also awesome.
I, I used it, uh, when I used to work in the office, um, at my last job.
And so I got one for home finally.
Nice dude.
Yeah.
I, um, I bought this DX racer, like when I graduated college.
So I haven't, I haven't, you know, changed at all since I, since I bought it.
But, um, to be honest, I mean, it does the job for me.
It's adjustable.
You know, um, the, the neck support and back support is pretty, lower back support is pretty
good.
Uh, it's not as adjustable as it could be, but you know, it's pretty good.
Um, and it's something that I haven't, I haven't spent a lot of time.
Um, optimizing, but I think at some point I will go ahead and buy Herman Miller.
Cause everyone, you know, raves about them.
Um, and, but like I said, you know, I don't actually feel a lot of aches and pains from
sitting.
And, uh, I, I saw a quote recently that that was from a respected, you know, posture physician
of sorts, you know, uh, and they were saying that the, the best posture for you to have is
one that changes every 15 minutes, essentially, you know, like as long as you're not leaning,
you know, if you've got your foot up on your desk and you're like, you know,
head crank to the side, that's fine for 10 minutes, you know, and then you kind of got
to move.
Um, so as long as you're not staying stagnant in one position for, you know, a long time,
it's, it's not too big of a deal.
I don't think.
Um, plus I use the standing desk feature of, of my, of my desk on a pretty regular basis.
So, um, I think the, the chair is a really good investment for most people that spend
a lot of time there.
Um, for me, it's a little bit lower on the punching list.
Yeah, for sure.
I, um, based on what I've read, those, those racing chairs are like the worst for your back,
but, but yeah, your mileage may vary.
Like some people have just like, you know, either they change their, their position a
lot or, or it doesn't, you know, bother them because they have a strong back or whatever,
whatever it is.
So, you know, whatever works for you, if you want some good chair reviews, there's a
YouTube channel that I really like.
Um, it's honestly, A H N E S T L Y.
Well, we'll get down below.
A H N honestly.
Yeah.
Like A H N.
Yes.
A H N.
Yeah.
E S T L Y.
And honestly, that's kind of interesting.
Yeah.
Interesting spelling on, on, on honestly, but yeah, no, he, uh, he does like that, like chair
reviews, but like videos and it goes like very in depth.
He compares them to like other high end chairs and all that kind of stuff.
He'll talk about like the drawback.
So it's like, you know, if you're looking at getting a chair, what a niche, nice chairs
are expensive.
You know, it's like $1,500, $2,000 for, for a nice chair.
And it's an investment that you're going to be sitting in for many, many years.
So I would recommend, um, do some research on it.
I bought actually during the pandemic, I bought a chair and I used it for like six months
and I hated it so much that I went back to my old chair, my old, my old air on.
I switched from an air on to like an office mat master something, something or other.
It was like 500 bucks.
And I was like, oh, this will be great.
It's got a headrest and all this stuff.
And I used it for six months and it was like creaking and it was like hard to use.
And it wasn't comfortable.
And I was like, screw this.
And I went back to my air on and I used that for another like two years before I got my body.
Nice, dude.
Yeah.
It's so funny to me, all these little niches that are all over the place, man.
This guy honestly has like 52K subscribers.
And it's just chairs.
It's just chairs.
It's just like, he's the chair guy, you know?
He's the chair guy.
It's crazy.
That's hilarious.
All right, man.
That's a, that's a wrap on what we had in the doc.
You got anything else before we bounce?
No, I don't think so.
I could, I could rant on and on about why I bought what I bought.
So we should probably end it before.
Yeah, we're going to cut it.
That's great.
All right, man.
Well, good luck in the, in the live hack event this week.
And yeah, I'll catch you next time.
Yeah, you too.
Catch you later.
All right.
Peace.
What's up, y'all?
Got some quick announcements for us at the end of the pod here.
One, NahamCon is going on this week.
So if you haven't signed up for that, head over to NahamCon.com.
And don't miss out on that awesome,
the awesome talks that are going to be given.
It's definitely going to be a banger this year.
So definitely watch that.
Also our producer here at Critical Thinking, Richie Mills,
has launched his new audio drama.
And I'm not going to lie.
I binge listened to the whole thing in the first day that it came out.
And it is real good.
So if you enjoy sci-fi fantasy,
give Homicide @HeavensGate a search,
and we'll drop it in the description below as well.
Definitely, definitely recommend.
Also, I wanted to announce, as I did last week,
re-announce that Jesse Rivera has joined the Critical Thinking podcast team.
He'll be doing the blog cast from now on.
So if you head over to criticalthinkingpodcast.io and drop your email,
you'll always be up to date on the awesome newsletters and text-based content he'll be putting out.
That's all for today.
See you next week.